so i get this question a lot how much vitamin
d should we be taking on a daily basis well i
think we should probably go to the experts right
the vitamin d council stated that healthy adults
which i'm still trying to find some healthy adults
need about 2000 ius that's international units
okay per day if you're getting little to
no sun other experts recommend 400 to 800
ius per day now here's the problem that i need
your help with okay i just don't understand this
when we take vitamin d it's in these units right
here international units but when they measure
the blood it's not in international
units it's in ngs per milliliter okay
so if you're deficient in your blood how do
we know how much vitamin d to take because the
units and supplements are ius okay so it's kind
of weird i it's i don't know why they do that
but if we take a look at the optimum concentration
in your blood of vitamin d it should be between
40 to 60 ngs per milliliter okay
so if you had 20 ngs per milliliter
that would be considered low right well let's
convert 20 ngs per milliliter to international
units per milliliter it would be 0.8 pretty small
but the question is how much blood do we have
because this is per milliliter not all of your
blood so we have about five liters of blood in
the average size person and that would give us if
we do the math four thousand international units
okay vitamin d so people that are deficient
that have only 20 ngs per milliliter
really have about 4000 international units
of vitamin d which is actually greater than
what is recommended there's some conflicting
information here isn't there all right so just
keep tracking with me here because if we take
the optimum concentration which is 40 to 60 okay
how much vitamin d is this in international units
well if you do the calculations it's 8000 to
9000 ius that's what's normal in your blood
so how are we going to get this if we're only
recommending this or that that's what i just
don't understand it doesn't make sense to me
and on top of that i don't think you're going to
absorb 100% of your supplements estimates show that
you really only absorb between 60 to 80 percent
that's in a healthy person of these vitamin
d supplements when you take them if you're
taking d3 not and so if we're only absorbing 60
to 80 percent and you took let's say 10,000 ius
in one day you're really only absorbing 6000
to 8000 international units of vitamin d3
which just barely make the normal amount
that you need in your blood so there's a
big problem here because these recommendations
do not match what we really need to normalize
our blood values and then on top of
that if you're taking these amounts
and you have a deficiency or you
have other problems like inflammation
or you don't have a gallbladder or you have gut
damage from past antibiotics or you're older or
you have insulin resistance or you are obese there
are so many barriers that are going to prevent you
from absorbing this vitamin d anyway what i would
recommend for the average person is to take at
least at least 10,000 ius every single day and on
top of that get some sun if you can just to meet
the minimum requirements that your body needs and
another point i want to bring up is that vitamin
d is the most important vitamin because it's so
important for your immune system to maintain a
healthy mood to keep inflammation out of your body
and not to mention your bone structure your teeth
so it's no wonder why the great majority of the
population is deficient in vitamin d so if you're
enjoying my content which i hope you are and
you're applying this knowledge to your health
and you have a success i would really appreciate
you sharing your success story so click the link
down below to my website where you can upload
your success story so you can help inspire others